un petit peu on est autour de 170 580
passages jours
[Musique]
en 20 ans de bronchiolite à l'hôpital
des enfants à Bordeaux nous n'avions
jamais déclenché le plan blanc or c'est
à peu près toujours la même épidémie
avec des variations un peu d'agressivité
du virus de temps de démarrage de
l'épidémie mais grosso modo c'est
toujours la même épidémie on sait qu'en
France il y a 20 000 hospitalisations
supplémentaires chaque année pour la
bronchiolite donc on sait tout ça et
bien cette année à Bordeaux on déclenche
le plan blanc ce qui montre bien que
c'est pas la bronchiotique le problème
c'est l'état de départ de l'hôpital ce
que vous avez derrière moi il n'y a pas
d'autres endroits où on fait ça nulle
part ailleurs on fait ça sinon à
l'hôpital public donc là spécificité la
technicité la qualité elle est dans les
services de soins critique pour prendre
des enfants les plus gravement malades
il faut donc que ces lits soient
ouvertes toute l'année et puis la
pression haute faudrait qu'elle soit
plutôt autour de 14 15 et on est à 22
[Musique]
nos professionnels de santé ils s'en
vont de l'hôpital du CHU parce que il ne
supporte plus de travailler dans ces
conditions les conditions d'accueil
c'est ça c'est extrêmement finalement
malgré ces nouvelles urgences qui sont
très grandes
elles servent finalement pour des lits
d'hospitalisation également ce qui est
pas sa fonction c'est vrai que je crois
que c'est une des premières fois où on
est dans un environnement comme ça avec
des chambres avec plusieurs box donc
c'est vrai que c'est pas l'idéal après
je me mets à la place des médecins il
essaie de faire au mieux mais c'est vrai
que tant de parents c'est vrai qu'on
aurait aimé avoir un espace un peu plus
intimiste et
un peu plus au calme pour pour pouvoir
se reposer aussi